thank you mr president you know as i sit
and listen to my esteemed colleague
um from virginia i can't agree more
now is the time really for us to come
together
to do what the senate traditionally does
best and that is
working on the best interests of the
people across this country who are
struggling right now compromise
it is not a bad word it is time for us
to
get in a room and really do the job that
the american public expects us to do
and that is looking out for their best
interests
at a time when we have
a healthcare pandemic now keep in mind
this is a once
in a lifetime pandemic once in a
lifetime
so that requires us to come together
and really focus on how we help
americans across this country
who are struggling right now they
shouldn't be penalized
we've asked them to stay home and
shelter in place
because we are trying to address how we
how we do the research that's necessary
for a vaccine
hopefully one day we have that vaccine
how we
ramp up the testing that is needed so
everybody can feel
safe and comfortable knowing whether
they have
this virus or not or the antibody but
we're not there yet
because more work needs to be done
particularly by this congress
but the american public has hurt us and
they are they're sheltering in place
they're staying home they've shuttered
their businesses
and now more than ever this country
needs the senate to act
the house has done its job two months
ago
they worked a comprehensive package
and and i say comprehensive because we
we can't just pick and choose winners
and losers here
this isn't what this is about this is
about making sure we're bringing relief
and helping those across this country
and
everybody is impacted because we've
promised them if you do what we say
and we help stem the spread of this
virus we're gonna we're gonna have your
backs
we're gonna take care of you
but i will say that we have failed at
that
this administration has failed we have
failed at that promise
and i know when we all go to our offices
or we go home to our states
we are hearing from our constituents we
get emails we get calls we get
letters i know you all feel the same as
i do
and we read them and we listen to them
and i don't know of one state in this
country right now that somebody's not
suffering from this pandemic
that needs our help
and i know that's why i'm here because
we have all
took the oath we said we're going to be
here working on
best interests of our states in this
country to make sure
that those individuals across this
country who pay
our salaries those taxpayers expect us
to do our jobs and work
and that's what i'm asking for right now
you know
i've been to the floor of the senate
this week to talk about the struggles
that i see
in in my state we all get letters and
and i do want to focus today
on on one and there's so many and that's
why a comprehensive package is necessary
but right now i i would love to talk to
you about what i am seeing mr president
in my home state when it comes to
our seniors and those who are in need
right now with funding to
help nursing homes and and let me just
start with with
letters because i think this is how it
starts with all of us calls into our
office letters
coming from our constituents and this
there's two calls that i received
and one of them was from a daughter who
called in for her father
who is in a va nursing home in boulder
city
nevada and because he isn't showing
symptoms he isn't getting tested with so
many cases there how is this possible
where are the tests
this is a daughter who's concerned for
her father
knowing that if we just get people
tested there is that comfort in knowing
whether or not
you have this virus and whether you
should be quarantined or how we protect
you
particularly those in nursing homes and
then another call i've received is a
mother
she's also a certified nursing assistant
at a nursing home
and she is telling me that many there
quit
because they don't have the proper ppe
they want to work but they don't want to
expose themselves
so what what are we doing right now
to address all of these needs and listen
there's so much
it's overwhelming i know it
but that's why we were sent here for the
hard decisions not the easy ones
to make sure we're all working for the
best interests of the people in our
states and i know you all feel the same
way
but i i i have to tell you this there
are thousands
of nevadans that know the anxiety that
comes because
there's a spouse a parent or a
grandparent in a nursing home
unable to visit with or hug their loved
ones for fear of giving covet 19
you have seen it you have heard it i
have heard it
too many loved ones have lost
their loved ones because of this virus
and they were not
able to be there you know who was there
with them in the nursing home
those incredible heroes on the front
lines who are sacrificing their own
health to be with them
for those who pass away because of
covid19
there are so many factors that raise the
coronavirus risk for nursing home
residents
the majority of residents we all know
are seniors many
have underlying conditions they live in
close quarters and they share common
spaces
and we also know this residents and
staff of these facilities shouldn't
be an afterthought they are a core part
of our communities and our health care
system
they are elders and they are the keepers
of our stories
we have to do more to protect them
and we need to protect the workers in
these homes too
many of whom belong to communities of
color
and who are struggling to provide care
to a population with unique needs
and the reason why i bring this up is
because there is legislation out there
to do
just what i'm talking about and what we
need in our communities
it's not something new it's already been
introduced my colleague bob casey
introduced the nursing home covet 19
protection prevention act
to get nursing and lawn care facilities
in nevada and across this country more
ppe the testing that they need
and the staffing and to help the staff
and those that are
in those communities these
homes need support to slow the spread of
the virus and to respond rapidly when it
does
crop up using all we've learned from
combating this virus so far
the bill funds teams of nurses and other
critical staff to
lend emergency help at nursing homes
with outbreaks
and to bring the best practices to bear
in helping
sick residents this bill ensures folks
in my home state and across the country
are being taken care of
that families have peace of mind that
there is accountability for providers
and protections in place for workers
i'm hearing from family members and
loved ones of those in nursing homes in
my state
i'm hearing from caregivers and health
care workers i know all of you are as
well
and one thing that comes from all these
people is a feeling
of being forgotten no one
no one mr president america should feel
forgotten right now
it's time for us to come together we
need to make sure nursing homes
follow guidelines and that if they fail
to do so they will be held accountable
but we also must arm them with the tools
they need to
face a virus that's been relentless in
attacking seniors
we should make sure that the next corona
virus package
that we should be negotiating and
working on right now
does everything it can to support the
most fragile in our communities
because they are also some of our most
precious